- Welcome back to our
post-game press conference.
We've got the cast of 80 for Brady here,
Jane Fonda, Lily Tomlin, Sally Field
and Rita Moreno everybody.
Everybody played a great
interview today, I feel.
Let's take some questions from the press.
Let's start with Nick.
Where are you Nick?
- Uh Kelly, right here.
Thank you so much.
Nick Krupke from FOX 12, Oregon.
This question is for Jane.
Earlier we saw Rita say
that she called you
for instructions in bed
and you had a curious look on your face?
Just wanted to know what
was going through your mind
at that moment?
- And do you have tips?
- Tits?
- Tips. (laughs)
- What'd she say?
- Tits.
- I did not say that HR.
- I do not have ti... I have not
and I never will have tips for Rita.
(crowd laughs)
- [Kelly] Just not Rita. (laughs)
- Now Lily, on the other hand.
(crowd laughs)
- You're just asking about
the wrong person. That's all.
- All right. Where is
Mark? Mark, are you...
- Yeah. Right here. Mark
McClune, Arizona's family.
Hey, so much was discussed today.
I'm wondering that the proudest
moment in the discussion.
And this question is for the whole panel
what you would've said and
done maybe differently.
And we'll start with you, Lily.
- Oh my gosh. Well, that's
why I didn't join in
It was...
(crowd laughs)
- Because you were ashamed?
- If I was like really deeply honest.
It was hard to compete with the
absolute uninhibited exposure.
But I've always looked
to them as influences
and I've hung on every
word that they've said.
(crowd laughs)
- Alright, let's go to Mario.
What's your question, Mario?
- Yeah. Mario Solis. NBC4 Los Angeles.
This question is for Rita.
You came out of the gate strong.
Dancing out of the helmet.
As a veteran in this game,
Do you think it sort of set the stage
for the rest of the players?
- Oh, that wasn't my intention.
I heard music. I moved.
(crowd laughs)
- That's what I do when I hear music.
- Look at Sally! (laughs)
- [Mario] Kelly, now I have a follow up.
- Okay. Follow up.
- So the follow-up
would be any of you wish
that you had also danced out like Rita?
- Oh God
- No.
(crowd laughs)
I do not.
- No. We all go out of
our way to give Rita...
- We have to give Rita her space.
- That's right. Yes.
- Her hips don't lie.
- I was trying very hard
behind her to dance.
I guess it didn't register.
- I have a question for one of you.
Whoever wants to answer
this, I have a problem.
And it came up a little bit
during the game now about tight ends.
(crowd laughs)
I don't know what it means.
Could you explain?
I want one, but I don't
know quite what it is. So...
- She appears to have found one.
- [Kelly] Its so tight.
What is a tight end?
That's a real question.
- A position on a football team.
It's a position on a football team.
It's a, it's a person that
plays the tight end position.
Its not on the body.
- But wait, but wait, they're
not the wide receiver.
- Why is it called tight end?
- Because he's...
because he's tighter in, he's closer.
- He's closer and always tighter in, okay.
- He's closer, right?
He's closer in.
- A little closer to the quarterback.
He's the receiver, runs the slot.
- Is there sort of like a little short
with only like two or three guys in there
and they've all got
tight ends and they're...
(crowd laughs)
up and bounce one another? I don't...
- And what do you do to get a tight end?
- Your workout videos.
- You play football.
- A lot of squats.
- Exactly. You do some
Jane Fonda working out.
That's what you do.
That's how I got my tight end.
All right. That is our show.
A big thank you to the
cast of 80 for Brady!
Jane Fonda, Lily Tomlin,
Sally Field ,Rita Moreno
and all the sports fans in our audience.
And thank you as well
to a Stephen A. Smith.
You love the Cowboys. I feel it.
His book, Straight Shooter,
a memoir of second chances and first takes
is in stores now, go pick it up y'all.
Have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.